oh my god this needs to be called out
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
in today's video we will be reviewing
teddy mellencamp's
controversial weight loss program all in
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor blue land now
like most people 2020 has turned me into
a
bit of a germaphobe and i spend an
inordinate amount of my time each day
washing my hands and washing my kids
hands
and literally washing everything else we
touch
so we go through a lot of hand soap and
cleaning supplies around here
so i was really excited when i heard
about these beautiful
cleaning products from blue land now
unlike traditional liquid hand soap or
household cleaners which
are sold in single-use plastics all you
need to get your hands
or house super clean is some water
and one of these nickel sized tablets
this cuts down on so much plastic waste
and also saves you money since each
tablet is just
two dollars compared to six to eight
dollars for a bottle of good soap
so to get cleaning you just fill your
forever bottle with some hot water
and you pop in your tablet and voila
you've got an amazing smelling soap
my personal favorite is the satsuma
mandarin
but they actually have six really great
smelling scents
i got the clean essentials kit and hand
soap duo
and when you get a kit like this you
automatically save
20 percent but if you use my promo code
abby 15
you'll get an additional 15 off of your
first order
so check out my link in the description
to learn more and get your kit today
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating
so please feel free to skip this video
if it's not supportive to your journey
as we will be talking a lot about
weight loss also don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode okay
so for those of you who are avid
watchers of the real housewives of
beverly hills
you may recognize teddy mellencamp as
the
accountability coach who joined the cast
in season eight
however teddy became the subject of some
major controversy
back in september of 2020 for her weight
loss program
all in now this is not to be confused
with the
all-in we've discussed on the channel
before in my stephanie buttermore review
right here
which is ironically more about weight
gain
so teddy's all-in is not just a
completely
opposite concept but it's also wildly
problematic
so with that said let's jump in
now for starters what does teddy's all
in program
look like well all in is described as an
accountability program
that focuses on weight loss and
detoxification
according to their mission statement the
all-in program aims to provide
clients a pathway to self-accountability
through
personal one-on-one support guidance
and tools that inspire a complete and
lasting
lifestyle shift towards health fitness
and achieving
one's best self now while i can totally
get on board with
taking steps to become your best and
healthiest self
i am highly skeptical about
whether or not all in is the right path
to get you there
but before we get into that let's take a
closer look at the program itself
all right step one jump start the
program kicks off with a
two-week detox called jumpstart
which is designed to detoxify your body
and
reset your habits toward a path of
health and wellness
now each client is paired with an
accountability coach who provides
one-on-one guidance with their meals and
physical activity
the program includes working out for an
hour a day
seven days a week through a combination
of
jogging spinning or hot yoga plus a
low calorie about 1200 calories clean
vegetarian diet with absolutely no
alcohol or dairy
obviously you also have to weigh
yourself every day
and submit the results to your coach to
keep yourself
accountable folks there is
already so much to unpack here i am
literally overwhelmed and this is only
the first
two weeks of the program but let's just
quickly roll out the rest of the
protocol shall we
you know just so you know you're getting
yourself into step two
is the monthly now after the jump start
program
clients progress to the monthly program
which consists of the same level of
personal coaching and
exercise but it claims to have a more
relaxed menu their words folks
not mine so it's still dairy free and
still
super low calorie but you can have the
option to add some animal protein to
breakfast or lunch
[Music]
step three is wait and workout okay so
now you're like
six weeks all in and you get to move
into the
weight and workout portion of the
program which involves a
daily weight check-in and cardio
so same same but
different anyway
once participants have achieved their
goal weight they move
on to the maintenance portion of the
program
in this phase check-ins are dialed back
slightly in their frequency
and it provides just the right touch
of accountability until you're ready to
graduate
um graduate into what
oh lord give me strength
give me strength to press on
all right now that we have already
covered each phase of the program
let's dive a little bit deeper and
discuss the five reasons
why you should avoid all in at all costs
number one the extreme caloric
restriction
now according to the minimal amount of
information on the website
the jumpstart program involves a 1200
calorie meal plan for two weeks
now unless you're my toddler my 40 pound
dog
or literally bedridden in long-term care
you need more than 1200 calories
a day the average female adult requires
anywhere between 1800 and 200 calories a
day depending
on their unique needs and physical
activity level so this means that
following the jumpstart program
automatically puts you in a 600 to 1000
calorie
deficit which my friends is no bueno
unfortunately former clients claim that
the actual
meal plan is much much lower than this
and usually provides only about 500 to
700 calories a day
uh yikes
his tummy sounds angry daddy that's his
stomach eating itself
to give you an example of what a typical
all-in-meal plan looks like
a former client shared the following
information now keep in mind that this
is totally anecdotal and we cannot
verify the accuracy of the meal plan
as no specific information is provided
on the all-in website
however this isn't the only first-hand
account of how
problematically low in calories the
suggested meal plan
is so for breakfast they would have
a half cup of oatmeal and some berries
for their morning and afternoon snack
they could have only
one piece of fruit or a small serving of
vegetables
for lunch they could have a half a cup
of rice with more vegetables
and for dinner they could have a bowl of
broth-based
soup that's it that is
literally all she wrote
i am hungry just thinking about this oh
got me a snack okay well i don't know
who approved
packaged and sold this meal plan but 500
calories
is one meal not an entire day's worth of
food
this right here is some extreme caloric
restriction
and coupled with the daily one hour
exercise requirement
is straight up inhumane starvation diets
like this can have some
seriously dangerous consequences like
muscle loss extreme hunger mood swings
fatigue dizziness and even fainting and
while this most definitely will lead to
weight loss
at what cost you are literally starving
yourself and pushing yourself to the
point of exhaustion
which is by no means a sustainable or
safe weight loss strategy you're also
setting yourself
up to potentially damage your metabolism
which can
increase the likelihood that
participants will regain that weight
back
over time and based on research that we
have
on the biggest loser which was another
similarly aggressive crash diet
there's a good chance that you would
gain back
even more if this extremely low calorie
miserable meal plan wasn't enough to
steer you away from all in perhaps the
next few points will
reason number two to run for the hills
are the unqualified
coaches so neither teddy or the
accountability coaches
have any background or specialized
training in nutrition and fitness
which is quite apparent by their insane
meal plan
because no credible nutrition
professional would approve that crap
and while i appreciate the transparency
of providing this information
on their website the lack of expertise
alone is a major red flag
having an interest in health and fitness
does not make somebody
qualified to dole out advice
on the subject and it's one thing if the
biggest problem
was just that people would waste their
money on crap advice and maybe wouldn't
lose weight or nothing would happen
but said crap advice can actually be
super dangerous as it clearly is
in this situation in my opinion all in
reads like a hollywood how-to for
disordered eating
so whether it is this program or any
other weight loss program
you should not be taking nutrition or
fitness advice from
somebody with no credible expertise hard
stop
number three is the excessive
weight tracking you're required to do so
weight loss is
essentially the only measure of success
for the all-in program
and is tracked through daily weigh-ins
they also have a no bullsh approach when
it comes to their daily weigh-ins
as some clients have reported being told
to pack a scale for a few days of travel
because there are no excuses
honestly that is so [ __ ]
up well i can understand the expectation
to regularly weigh yourself as part of a
weight loss program
there is absolutely no need to weigh
yourself
every single day or to even take
pictures of yourself
in fact weighing yourself daily can
actually lead to
weight fixation body dissatisfaction and
anxiety
especially if the anticipated day-to-day
progress
is not achieved or seen it's also really
important to mention that it is
totally normal for our weight and body
shape
to fluctuate on a daily basis and also
from
within the same day from things like
your menstrual cycle
medication stress sleep
water weight constipation what you just
ate etc
so obsessively weighing yourself every
single day
is not actually a good indicator of
overall weight loss
and looking at the shape or size of your
body
throughout the day is also not an
indicator of success
we need to start normalizing our stomach
expanding and contracting over the day
as a
healthy bodily process now
that said weighing yourself no more than
once a week
is totally sufficient for tracking
progress and i also think it's just as
important
to look for other short-term health
measures outside of the scale
so consider things like improved mood
digestion
energy levels and concentration but
let's be real i'm pretty sure
if those things were measured on teddy's
all-in program
it would be pretty obvious your health
and well-being
was taking a [ __ ] kicking
so yeah i guess it makes sense that all
of these important aspects of health
are left out teddy cares about one thing
and one thing only shrinking your body
at
any expense and that brings me to reason
number four
it's expensive as it's no surprise that
a weight loss program developed by a
real housewife is gonna cost you a
pretty penny
so let's break down those numbers for
starters
the two week jumpstart program costs 599
dollars for two weeks
which averages out to forty dollars a
day the monthly
program costs 399 dollars a month
which is approximately 15 a day
the weight and workout program costs 165
dollars a month
which is about six dollars a day and
finally the maintenance program is 95
a month which is about 3.40 cents per
day
this adds up to a total of 1258.
so for a little over a grand and a big
chunk of your mental sanity
you get a meal plan that basically just
suggests you live on
air and sadness and a coach to pull you
into living
onset plan that's it that's basically it
the cost of your exercise regimen is on
you
as no personal training or exercise
classes are covered by the cost of the
program
purchasing and cooking the food on the
mail plan is also
obviously on you but i imagine that
wouldn't cost you a ton of money anyway
since
you're essentially only eating like a
few vegetables and some soup
anyway in a nutshell for one not so easy
payment of twelve hundred dollars
you get a low calorie miserable meal
plan
that was not even developed by a
nutrition professional
and you're essentially being bullied
every day by an
unqualified coach to suppress your
hunger
exercise beyond your limits and weigh
yourself
as proof of your success sounds like a
[ __ ] nightmare and a kind of
way to spend your hard earned money if
you ask me what's worse
is that if you don't comply with these
bullsh parameters of
health you receive a threat that you'll
be kicked out of the program
you think you can do this to me bringing
me to
my last point the borderline shady
practices clients have reported that
failure to adhere to any aspect of the
program
results in immediate dismissal with no
option for a refund
this includes eating anything outside of
the restrictive meal plan
also skipping a daily one hour workout
not participating in the daily weigh-ins
and or
failure to provide proof of all of the
above
who are these people is this a [ __ ]
cult
obviously i'm not suggesting it is but
man this is next level control
to get a sense of just how intense the
program can be
let's take a quick peek at one coach's
introductory text
to a client hi stephanie before i accept
anyone or give specifics i give the
rules
i have never had anyone lose less than
seven pounds on the program
if they're doing it properly you cannot
drink alcohol at all
and have to follow a low calorie diet
exactly
and send me photo proof of everything if
you aren't willing to do that
then it's not worth your time also if
you fall off the food or alcohol wagon
then i drop you immediately and will not
return the money
this is what gives you the
accountability factor and the willpower
to not
cheat whoa this coach
must be getting some major incentives to
be so aggressive in her sales pitch
but it sounds like the usual
fear-mongering tactics
that we hear from die culture every day
with of course a side of major attitude
you know things like if you don't lose x
amount of weight by this amount of time
you're not doing it properly and you
need to work harder if you
don't eat this food or exercise this way
you're not committed
if you fall off the wagon and eat a
forbidden food you have
no willpower you've heard it all before
this type of fear-based messaging from
all in
is extremely damaging to a person's
relationship with food
their body and their mind a former
client even said that if your weight
goes up
even a couple of ounces you're chastised
and told to cut out a meal or a snack
from the
already super limited meal plan
this actually drove this particular
client to not only
binge on foods outside of the meal plan
but to also make herself throw
up out of fear of getting caught folks
this needs to be called
out this is not normal sustainable
weight loss
is possible but if it drives you into
the binge restrict cycle
there is something seriously wrong and
you need to abort mission right away
any program that makes you feel guilty
for adding dressing to your salad
skipping a workout or eating i don't
know actual food because you are
hungry instead of just drinking more
water to suppress your hunger
is crazy dangerous and should be avoided
at all costs
i would love to make the suggestion that
all in brings in an actual nutrition
professional
to oversee clients and cases but no
professional in their right mind would
ever want to be aligned with a program
as problematic
as this what's even more suspect
is that clients are expected to sign
ndas
which is why a lot of the details about
the harmful practices of the program
have been so hush-hush it wasn't until
former clients began to
anonymously expose all in on social
media
that the restrictive nature of the
program was revealed
now i know that there's a certain allure
when your favorite hot celebrity
housewife is
pitching their wellness program because
it gives you the perception that
you could get a little taste of their
glamorous
hollywood lifestyle but please be wary
of
anyone who is using their celebrity
rather than their expertise
to sell a diet program 99
of the time it is a complete money grab
that will just not equip you with the
tools that you need
to live a healthy happy life because
yeah
in the case of all in it's likely to do
the opposite
so on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today folks
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below about what you
would like to see in your view next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here